The Time That Pre-Sliced Bread was Illegal
In 1943, Claude R. Wickard, the head of the
War Foods Administration as well as the Secretary
of Agriculture, got the bright idea to ban
pre-sliced bread in America, which he did
on January 18, 1943.
The specific reasons behind this aren’t
entirely clear, though it was about conservation
of resources, particularly generally thought
to have been about conserving wax paper, wheat,
and steel.
With regards to the wax paper conservation,
by FDA regulations, pre-sliced bread used
much thicker wax paper than loaves sold whole,
due to the fact that sliced bread, not surprisingly,
goes stale significantly faster than loaves
left unsliced.
While this was the official stated reason
for the ban, there was no shortage of wax
paper at the time the ban was put in place;
according to the War Production Board, most
bread making companies had wax paper supplies
on hand to last several months, even if they
didn’t buy anymore during that span.
It has also been suggested that a secondary
goal was to try to conserve wheat and to lower
bread and flour prices.
Around WWII, the Office of Price Administration
had authorized an increase in flour prices
by about 10%.
This naturally resulted in the price of bread
increasing.
When pre-sliced bread was first introduced
nation-wide, it drastically increased bread
sales.
So, the thought was that by banning pre-sliced
bread, the amount of bread consumed would
go down.
This would then reduce the demand for flour
and wheat, and, thus, decrease prices of those
products while simultaneously increasing stockpiles
of wheat.
As with the wax paper reasoning, the idea
of conserving wheat seems an odd thing given
that, at the time of the ban, the U.S. had
stockpiled over 1 billion bushels of wheat.
This is enough to meet the United States’
needs for about two years, even if no new
wheat was harvested over that span.
Finally, bread making machines themselves
used quite a bit of steel in their production;
so it has been suggested that one of the reasons
for this bread ban was to conserve this metal.
This line of reasoning also seems somewhat
dubious as most bread manufacturers weren’t
actively buying new bread slicing machines
at any given time; so the benefit would be
marginal, even accounting for the machine’s
large size and significant amount of metal
used in its production.
As you might imagine, banning pre-sliced bread
didn’t go over very well with the masses.
“The best thing since sliced bread” is
an expression for a reason.
As one woman aptly put it in a letter appearing
in The New York Times:
I should like to let you know how important
sliced bread is to the morale and saneness
of a household.
My husband and four children are all in a
rush during and after breakfast.
Without ready-sliced bread I must do the slicing
for toast—two pieces for each one—that’s
ten.
For their lunches I must cut by hand at least
twenty slices, for two sandwiches apiece.
Afterward I make my own toast.
Twenty-two slices of bread to be cut in a
hurry!
Within about three months of the ban being
introduced, on March 8, 1943, it was rescinded.
Upon lifting the ban, Wickard stated, “Our
experience with the order, however, leads
us to believe that the savings are not as
much as we expected…”